bom o ataque mais uma vez a é ok ok essa
linda fotografia sou eu a do colo claro
eu não tenho muitas fotografias dessa
minha época de infância quando criança
mas eu tenho muitas lembranças e uma das
memórias mais forte que eu tenho dessa
época é uma imagem
sentada assim na varanda da casa junto
com meus três irmãos em volta da minha
mãe
estávamos em cima de um monte de panos
rasgados costurados eu não sei acho que
aquilo era um retalhos na verdade eram
eram restos de tecido ea minha mãe
comprava do mala de uma fábrica de
tecidos e confecções daquilo que sobrava
dois dos corpos e compravam preço barato
para a partir daquilo construir novas
peças ela costurava e fazia novas peças
para vender na praça no mercado
eu acho que era umas roupinhas de
criança com até 500 eu não lembro
direito o que eu sei é que aquilo era
uma das muitas formas que ela eo meu pai
encontraram para sustentar quatro filhos
pequenos
eu sou de 81 ea minha infância passa por
um contexto social e político em angola
cheio de desafios principalmente parar
né
só assim como meus pais que tenham
quatro filhos pequenos para sustentar a
época da guerra é muitas dificuldades o
sistema era complicado e o acesso alguns
bens necessidade básica nem sempre eram
tão simples mas nós tivemos uma infância
com tudo assegurado comida na mesa
educação formal e valores que quanto
mais velho o retorno mas eu vejo
supletivos naquilo que a minha
trajetória e como representação do lugar
que hoje ocupo como mulher como pessoa
com profissional
os meus pais assim como muitos da
geração deles saíram do emprego do país
para a capital
empurrados pela guerra pela busca de sua
existência pela sobrevivência e
construíram uma história que me ensinou
lições valiosas disse mais sobre
empreendedorismo e e e aquilo que pra
eles era mecanismos de vivência de
sobrevivência e tiveram um impacto tão
grande
a idéia na época e me ensinaram muito
sobre transformação sobre criatividade
sobre busca oportunidades e também a
passar a ter um olhar para aquilo que
são os pequenos gestos e vivências
daquilo que é o nosso cotidiano dentro
da nossa realidade hoje nós estamos aqui
num evento dessa fruta para falar sobre
as raízes e acho que assim como alguns
jogadores k max deram eu acho muito
difícil por mais que eu trago aqui uma
proposta pra falar um pouco sobre aquilo
que é o meu trabalho dentro da área de
gestão dos recursos humanos
eu acho difícil fazê lo sem falar sobre
família porque eu sei
acredito que assim como eu todos que
estão aqui presentes têm noção da
importância das figuras que representam
a base daquilo que nós no total essas
figuras
às vezes vem formas pai avô rio o mesmo
cadastro aqueles são diferenças né
trazemos conosco mas dentro da nossa
cultura essa relação de família é tão
forte tão importantes que nós chamamos
paizinho mãezinha pio e havana não só
aquelas pessoas que são os nossos
parentes diretos nem vai muito além
daquilo que são os laços consangüíneos
a lógica é aquela do cuidado do respeito
da autoridade que aparece ali estendendo
muito além disso e vai pra que são por
exemplo aquela senhora pela conhecemos
aquela tia da igreja ou aquela vizinha
que às vezes não empresta o sal por
exemplo eu não sei
mas em angola chamada de tia é sinal de
que algum respeito aliás conquistou né
é um é um tipo vence na vida
só que essas relações nem sempre são
assim tão fácil de explicar
principalmente para quem não está
inserido dentro dessa realidade
agora imagina ter que explicar isso para
um povo nórdico sentado lá na direção de
uma empresa de uma multinacional na 9ª
pega preocupados em tragédia de gestão
global
preocupados em resultados pois é eu
passei por isso foi mais ou menos em
eu era responsável por recursos humanos
de uma empresa norueguesa e eu tive que
está assentada em reuniões para explicar
o que era o peso do significado de tia
dessa relação teria dentro da nossa
cultura a história é a seguinte a crise
e era havia necessidade de emitir algum
pessoal claramente justificado por
aquilo que eram os resultados da empresa
eis que vem uma lista né a noruega com
vários nomes incluídos inclusive o nome
da filha manuela não dela na verdade é
maria manuela turismo mas era a tia mas
leva até a manuela era uma senhora e
começou a trabalhar na empresa na área
da limpeza desde o início das operações
em angola foi aprendendo inglês
arrastado a lhe ensinam português putz
patriados também irão uma cópia daqui
receber um documento ele e ela virou
assistente administrativa barra
recepcionista algum cargo assim enfim
na verdade aquilo era o cargo formal ela
tinha mas todos absolutamente todos na
empresa do diretor geral ao motorista ii
nacionais e expatriados todos sabiam que
ela era a tia a noel até a maneira como
eu já disse em estagnação da estrutura
mas ela na verdade tinha papéis muito
além disso era uma espécie de
coordenadora geral de recursos humanos
era o centro da comunicação ela mandava
em todos e todos obedeciam
não havia nada nós chegávamos a ter medo
ela imitava mas ao mesmo tempo era uma
espécie de coaching de coordenadora ela
estava sempre aconselhar inclusiva nos
ajudar a encontrar alguns caminhos em
relação às tomadas se vão só que
claramente o povo lado a noruega não
sabia disso e o engraçado né era aquela
situação deles a perguntarem mas porque
com alguns problemas porque até amanhã
ela tem que ficar porque quando nós
vimos o nome dela estava na lista
nós sabíamos que éramos todos trabalho
não é que os outros as outras pessoas
não tinham valor eu não tenho outro time
mas é assim ela né
era difícil explicar esse lá pra cima e
quando eles iam permitir vamos
claramente conseguir com que é recrutar
uma outra pessoa no futuro quando for
necessário nós sonhamos a mão na cabeça
do tipo isso é realmente uma grande
marca para terem uma ideia do impacto
disso todos os trabalhadores naquela
época assinará um termo colocando os
seus cargos à disposição da empresa não
voltasse atrás em relação a essa decisão
nós poderíamos muito em termos de
comunicação em termos de vários fatores
motivação pra resumir a história nós
conseguimos até a manuela acontecer
quanto mais uma empresa ela continuar
por muito mais anos nós conseguimos
provar o impacto que aquilo seria a
nível da organização
essa é apenas uma das muitas histórias
que acontecem nos dias de hoje
principalmente principalmente nesse
processo é cada vez mais comum e
internacionalização das empresas
essas empresas que vão estendendo ali as
suas cadeias de operação por diversos
países e a proposta dessas empresas a
estratégia é sempre ter ali sistemas de
gestão que são globais com procedimentos
que vem lá da empresa-mãe da matriz e se
propõe ser né comuns em todos os locais
onde elas operam obviamente elas trazem
consigo os valores vinculados à empresa
mãe e altar em contato com as outras
culturas
essas novas realidades o contato com
outro seja ele profissional local os
clientes e os fornecedores os amigos
enfim é uma autoridade locais vai
causando ali sempre umas algumas
disparidades que nem sempre são muito
bem conduzida desenvolvidos
então não é difícil nós pensarmos
algumas dificuldades que existem nem os
gráficos que existem dentro das relações
de trabalho dentro das empresas
há sempre um desfasamento aquilo que é o
procedimento vai lá em cima ea prática
real e causa um certo desconforto
esse desconforto eu vivi dentro de
algumas empresas globais que eu
trabalhei como fez descobrir essa
palavra que bonita que é a antrop
tecnologia
a tropa tecnologia é um conceito que já
vem sendo estudado por alguns estudiosos
a nível do mundo e ela chama a atenção
justamente para dentro das realidades
nos locais onde há transferência de
tecnologia nós olharmos para aquilo que
é a realidade local e quando nós falamos
em tecnologia não é apenas em termos de
equipamentos têm a ver com os moldes do
furacão e termos do processo em termos
de procedimentos sempre vai haver ali
algum distanciamento quanto ao contato
com esse contexto local que causa alguma
disparidade e faz com que a gestão do
trabalho tem que ser diariamente de
vista porque aqueles aqueles processos
que às vezes não são é pensado naqueles
nos dentro daquilo que são os planos de
internacionalização ao entrar em contato
com essas novas culturas fazem com que a
organização do trabalho tem ali algumas
lacunas ali algumas falhas algumas
insuficiências então os trabalhadores
são obrigados a ter conta a forma de
regular ali aquelas práticas no dia a
dia porque as variabilidades que eles
enfrentam no meio vai sempre ter aí
alguns desafios vai exigir uma
flexibilidade enorme
há sempre de superar obstáculos
há sempre que adaptar a sempre que haver
flexibilidade porque algumas pessoas
dentro da nossa realidade enfrentam isso
por exemplo para chegar à outra
pra nós às vezes é difícil explicar mas
por exemplo pra empresa lá da noruega e
vamos atrasar um processo de
transferência dos pedidos de finanças ou
algum dinheiro porque o banco
simplesmente assim sistema curso três
dias acontece ou às vezes um documento
vai atrasar um processo importantíssimo
porque o teu lado da repartição tem que
assinar o documento relata um óbito
durante uma semana e não apareceu há
regulações que são necessárias e isso é
a nossa realidade e nós temos que olhar
pra isso eu quero deixar claro que aqui
não se questiona a necessidade de
existirem processos padrões que a versão
de sacar de padrões para existir regras
a nível do coração o que funciona aqui
essa inflexibilidade é uma certa
cegueira em relação àquilo que são as
singularidades locais
é essa a rigorosidade tão fortes que às
vezes acaba por dispor sinalizar aquilo
que é o indivíduo o próprio trabalhador
o desafio para as empresas que operam
dentro desse processo de
internacionalização é não ignorar aquilo
que é a sociedade a cultura o contexto
mas sim chegar nessas diferenças nessas
universidades e transformar em potência
para poder obter melhores resultados
porque aquilo que é a nossa cultura a
nossa história os governos as raízes são
determinantes na fatores que não podem
ser postos de parte naquilo que são os
processos de gestão porque a forma como
os países vivem a forma como nós
convivemos vão necessariamente
influenciar naquilo que é a forma como
nós gerimos o trabalho naquele processo
diário a tropa tecnologia na verdade
nada mais é do que nós considerarmos
valorizamos aquilo que são as nossas
potencialidades internas falar da tropa
tecnologia é falar sobre as nossas
rabidantes
falei certo eu tive o privilégio de
conhecer ontem uma visita no mercado
municipal porque são mulheres que estão
ali a nos ensinar reinventando sempre
formas estratégicas de gestão e vão nos
dando lições diárias do comércio sobre
atendimento ao cliente sobre negociação
sobre gestão de estoque e às vezes tão
até além daquilo que muitas vezes nós
estudamos os melhores mba do mundo falar
sobre a propor tecnologia é falar sobre
o valor agregado existe na proposta de
de atendimento de gestão que nos faz às
vezes trocar alguns restaurantes top com
certificado michelin e sentar em algumas
barracas pra comer esse peixe lá no
fundo da chicala na ilha do norte
falar da tropa tecnologia é falar sobre
a joaquina que assim como muitos
africanos vive do negócio formal anos
tentou os filhos até hoje sustenta
várias famílias dentro desse propósito
falar da antrop tecnologia é falar sobre
amor a beleza e nós talvez não sabíamos
explicar eu no lugar que ocupo não sabia
explicar também como os verdadeiros cabo
verdianos mas nós sentimos a partir do
momento que nós pisamos aqui no
aeroporto e da forma como fomos
recebidos e atendidos e amor aberta é
tão forte que deveria ser é
institucionalizado deveria ser
valorizada ao ponto de ser incluído
naquilo que são os currículos escolares
dentro da ajudado nas áreas de hotelaria
smo de turismo aqui em cabo verde e no
mundo
falar da procura da protecção elogia é
falar sobre aquilo que é a vivência dos
retalhos dos tecidos e as lições de
empreendedorismo isso trouxe falar sobre
a tecnologia é falar sobre as cheias
manuela é falar sobre nós às vezes temos
lá diretores-gerais chefe ministro
o folha termos cargos importantes
estarem envolvidos em regiões é super
culpados mas se eu me pergunto cinema da
minha mãe a dizer que eu tenho pra praça
comprar aquilo não vi porque meu pai tá
com vontade de comer
eu vou ter que parar tudo não interessa
que eu sou ocupada eu não vou conseguir
mandar ninguém não é isso que dita
regras dentro da nossa sociedade
nós vamos ter que fazer porque ali um
processo uma era que aqui em raízes e é
o que dita regras dentro da nossa
realidade
independente de ser de 13 anos 27 ou
quase 40 é assim que funciona e pronto
a mensagem que eu gostaria de deixar
aqui a todos principalmente para aqueles
que estão envolvidos nos processos de
gestão de recursos humanos e aqueles em
posições de direção é que a gente
consiga
a mensagem que eu queria deixar aqui é
que nós possamos ter
ok a mensagem é que possamos de alguma
forma ter um olhar para as nossas
práticas de gestão que nós possamos
repensar essas práticas e olhar para
modelos de gestão e reduzam
estranhamento em relação às diferenças
que de alguma forma
valorizem a nossa cultura é preciso
criar espaços do trabalho que valorize
isso e assumem essa adversidade as
multiplicidades e que afirmem essas
diferenças
isso só vai ser possível se nós
apurarmos o nosso olhar para modelos de
trabalho uma noção do trabalho e vai
muito além daquilo que é uma mera
repetição daquilo que são as atividades
nós temos pensar em noções mais
subjetivas do trabalho onde estão
presentes ali escolhas atividades do
trabalho não está presente sempre
escolhas e dentro dessas escolhas tão
presente valores seja a nível individual
ou coletivo e principalmente dentro da
realidade como a nossa exigem sempre um
repensar daquilo que são as nossas
práticas de gestão
obrigado